pokemon go's interaction distance has
been increased again fortnite celebrates
dr martin luther king jr plus activision
blizzard is accused of shredding
evidence my name is davonte chisholm and
you're watching gamespot news
first up let's talk about pogo pokemon
go will be returning the interaction
radius of pokestops and gems to 80
meters following an outcry from fans
developer niantic announced the change
on twitter adding that the interaction
distance would remain 80 meters quote
from now on niantic had previously
announced that it was putting together
an internal task force to address fans
concerns about the reduced interaction
distance it said that it would announce
more changes and findings from the task
force on september 1st the interaction
distance in pokemon go was originally 40
meters however that distance had been
doubled in response to covid making it
easier for players to interact with
pokestops and gyms without having to
physically interact with other people
are you still playing pokemon go let me
know in the comments
switching gears to fortnite epic games
and time studios of time magazine have
teamed up to present the fortnite march
through time a limited time mode that
offers no combat building or any of the
usual sword fortnite is known for
playing more like in assassin's creed
discovery tour mode the fortnite march
through time gives players a virtual
museum to explore all in celebration of
the important work done by dr martin
luther king jr in a blog post epic games
said march through time immerses players
in the entirety of dr king's monumental
i have dream speech and the history
surrounding it players who venture into
the mode will journey to washington dc
circa 1963 where they'll witness
recreations of famous landmarks such as
the lincoln memorial and united states
national mall where the famous speech
was delivered by king almost 58 years to
the day epic is hoping to open a
dialogue in its massive fortnite
community and is urging players to share
how dr king or another important person
in their life has inspired them using
the hashtag
fndc63
but okay in an update to its
anti-discrimination lawsuit against
activision blizzard the california
department of fair employment and
housing has accused the video game
conglomerate of shredding evidence
related to the investigation according
to axios the dfeh said that activision
blizzard has engaged in activity that
made it non-compliant with the
investigation the dfeh called out the
company's human resource personnel for
tearing up documents which it says
violates activision blizzard's legal
obligations to retain pertinent
information the document also called
attention to the hiring of law firm
wilmer hale and said requiring employees
to speak to the company before going to
the dfeh directly interferes with the
agency's ability to investigate
prosecute and remedy workplace
discrimination and harassment violations
on behalf of employees and contingent or
temporary workers the amended lawsuit
also changes its classification of the
group it claims activision blizzard
discriminated against axios noted the
word employees has been replaced with
workers to include contract or temporary
workers the company periodically
shuffles through for projects when
reached out for comment about destroying
evidence an activision blizzard
spokesperson said the claims were false
and that the company took appropriate
steps to retain relevant information
but alright that's it for today make
sure you hit gamespot.com for more
stories just like these and subscribe on
youtube for more awesome videos
[Music]
you